on ne peut gouverner ainsi
vous ne pourrez gouverner longtemps
ainsi cette fois pour votre huitième
utilisation du 49-3 avant le 9e dans
quelques heures vous n'avez Elisabeth
borne même pas lisser le temps d'une
seule minute de débat à chacun de ces
49,3 vous avez innové dans les prétextes
cette fois il s'agirait du calendrier du
budget perturbé par les leçons de
censure de France insoumise
devant un tel toupet vous avez du
sourire sous le cap cette fois c'est
l'histoire de l'oeuf et de la poule car
pour qu'il y a une émotion de censure
soit la seule façon que nous avons
trouvé pour redonner le droit de voter
au Parlement il a bien fallu même le
Premier ministre qu'il y ait 49-3
un autre de vos députés assorti son rire
pourquoi discuter puisqu'on sait qu'il
ne voteront pas pour voilà donc la façon
dont vous considérez désormais le
Parlement après être privé de vote le
voilà de privé de débat au prétexte que
l'opposition voudrait s'opposer que la
seule raison pour laquelle vous avez
annoncé votre 403 sans même cette fois
laisser les groupes s'exprimer c'est
qu'il y avait une notion de rejet
préalable sur laquelle vous aviez peur
d'être minoritaire tout revient à cela
vous privez l'assemblée de son droit
essentiel celui de le voter parce que
vous y êtes minoritaire vous avez ouvert
une plaie pour la 8ème fois l'assemblée
donc elle a souveraineté nationale parce
que vous y êtes minoritaire collecte des
parties gouvernementaux derrière vous
applaudissements qui ont de nouveau
accueilli cette sentence qui vous prive
pourtant vous aussi de votre raison
d'être ici se cache le soulagement de
ceux qui sont minoritaires
le 49-3 est d'habitude à pizalet pour un
gouvernement cherchant à éviter la
fronde de quelques-uns de sa majorité ou
bien une obstruction parlementaire c'est
déjà une blessure faite à notre
conception de la démocratie celle d'une
démocratie parlementaire pleine et
entière à l'opposé de la monarchie
présidentielle qui est la 5e République
mais là il s'agit de quelque chose
d'encore plus grave vous utilisez le
49-3 parce que vous vous savez
minoritaire dans les deux chambres du
Parlement vous êtes minoritaire donc
vous supprimez le vote dans combien de
démocraties réelles peut-on procéder
ainsi dans le monde vous n'utilisez pas
le 49-3 contre des oppositions mais bien
contre l'Assemblée nationale et son
droit qui devrait être intangible de
voter les lois et en l'espèce le budget
dès lors vous aviez le choix que vous
avez fait mine d'ouvrir dans les
dialogues de Bercy composé avec le
Parlement ou bien le soumettre par la
brutalité du 49.3 il vous aurait même
été possible de tenir compte de cette
nouvelle donne votre situation de
minoritaire dans l'utilisation du 49-3
en y intégrant par exemple des votes
manifestement majoritaires ou Parlement
si tu étais au moins une façon de
reconnaître un état de fait et par de la
souveraineté de la représentation
nationale quelques exemples la CVA
contribution sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises pour commencer ici en
première lecture vous avez arrêté les
débats juste avant l'article 5 certains
que vous seriez contre un effacer ou au
moins de reporter sa suppression la même
sentence vous est d'ailleurs venu du
Sénat résultat vous imposez sa
suppression par le 49-3 pourtant même
des députés plutôt économiquement
libéraux ici vous alerte est-ce normal
que vous fassiez payer à tous les
Français par plus de déficit ou par une
baisse des dépenses publiques bien les
deux c'est 4 milliards de baisse de
fiscalité des entreprises qui plus est
qui bénéficieront aux trois quarts au
grosses entreprises est-ce normal alors
que le chef de l'État ne met lui-même a
toute croissance d'un demi point un demi
point 14 milliards inférieur à celui des
1% que vous avez maintenu mordicus et
contre toutes les prévisions des
organismes internationaux pour établir
votre budget ces 4 milliards de recettes
volatilisées auraient été pourtant bien
utile quand il faudra pallier ces
différences dans votre impact budgétaire
ici votre entêtement idéologique est une
erreur économique funeste mais en plus
il prive le Parlement de son rôle
premier sur lui-même qui fut son acte
fondateur décidé de l'impôt
les deux chambres avaient aussi toutes
les deux voté sous des formes
différentes pour plus de moyens accordés
aux rénovations thermiques vous le
reposez un réalisme qui vous conduit à
limiter la progression du budget de
cette partie essentielle de la
nécessaire transition écologique en
dessous de l'inflation ce réalisme-là
est aveugle votre incurie a proposé un
budget suffisant pour répondre aux
besoins environnementaux n'a d'égal que
votre cynisme a trouvé des solutions
indignes comment pouvez-vous choisir
comment choisissez-vous d'aider l'Office
français de la biodiversité qui manque
de moyens humains et joue un rôle
important en augmentant son budget non
en créant à l'auto de la biodiversité
voilà l'importance qui accorde votre
gouvernement à la protection de
l'environnement lui augmenter le budget
de l'OSB au moment où la COP15 tirait
aussi le signal d'alarme de la sixième
extinction des espèces vous faites de
l'État le croupier de la Française des
Jeux
philosophiquement c'est un
affaiblissement de l'État peut-on
accepter qu'une politique majeure soit
financée de manière aussi incertaine
après le loto du patrimoine le loto de
la biodiversité jusqu'où ira votre
imagination à bingo pour les sans-abris
un poker contre la pauvreté c'est cette
proposition et d'autant plus indigne
qu'elle encourage les jeux d'argent nous
savons qui sont ces personnes qui sont
dans l'addiction les plus jeunes et les
plus défavorisés en leur donnant une
bonne raison de jouer vous ne faites
qu'entraîner encore plus l'addiction
selon taux de la biodiversité a été
rejeté à droite comme à gauche supprimer
au Sénat et en commission y compris avec
le vote de membres de votre majorité
mais vous le gardez et alors que nous
vous optiez le manque de moyens dans un
budget prétendument à l'euro près vous
créez une nouvelle niche fiscale pour
les captifs de réassurance par cet
article vous permettez aux entreprises
qui créent une filiale de réassurance de
pouvoir déduire de leur bénéfice les
fonds transférés assez filiales
d'assurance autrement dit elles peuvent
alors ma modifier leur bénéfice
artificiellement transférant des fonds
vers ces d'une part c'est un nouveau
cadeau grandes entreprises ce que vous
connaissez une seule PME disposant d'une
captive d'assurance
publicie totale elle ont créé des
captifs d'assurance pourtant je doute
qu'elles aient besoin de nouvelles
niches pour les protéger d'autre part
vous justifiez cette niche par le fait
qu'on l'absence de celle-ci les grandes
entreprises créent des captives mais au
Luxembourg au Luxembourg ou en Suisse
alors pragmatique vous préférez aligner
la législation fiscale française sur
celle de ces états faire de la France à
paradis fiscal plutôt lutter contre
l'évasion je vous applaudis ce n'est pas
de la demande c'est pas pourtant la
demande des Français
sur la forme votre retraite ces
dispositions du premier texte de loi des
finances issus du 49.3 devaient
illustrer votre prétendu volonté
d'écoute votre prévention prétendue
volonté des coudes Bruno Le Maire l'a
illustré en retirant cet amendement à la
demande de Valérie rabot votre prétendu
volonté d'écoute Elisabeth borne la
illustré en intégrant pas cette
proposition dans le texte post 49-3 mais
cette volonté d'écoute a désormais
disparu puisque cette proposition fait
désormais partie du projet de loi
l'écoute des députés disparaît après un
mois mais l'écoute des lobbys elle elle
reste puisque ce sont les lobbys de ces
très grandes entreprises qui sollicitent
à telle dispositif et vous le savez au
nom de la parole que vous aviez deviné
dans cette hémicide Madame Élisabeth
borne je vous demande solennellement
d'écouter la représentation nationale et
de retirer cette disposition du texte de
loi
ces méthodes vous ne pourrez pas les
prolonger très longtemps écoutez les
lobbies muselés les oppositions
parlementaires n'est pas un projet
démocratique hier le PLFSS aujourd'hui
le PLF demain les retraites par un PLFSS
rectificatif qu'on nous annonce votre
gouvernance à coup de 49,3 ne durera pas
votre autoritarisme aveugle aux besoins
des Français non plus vous surdité aux
appels des députés dessinateurs des
citoyens et intenables face à l'ampleur
des crises sociales énergétiques et
écologiques que nous traversons et
esprit tout aussi intenable c'est votre
obstination à détruire notre modèle
social pour ne surtout pas puiser du
côté des revenus du capital pour nous
permettre de nous en sortir
collectivement demain encore les
Français marcheront et manifesteront
pour s'opposer à votre projet unique de
faire payer la crise et vos cadeaux au
plus grandes entreprises par le plus
grand nombre dans votre projet de
retraite minoritaire ou Parlement
minoritaire face aux syndicats unanime
minoritaire dans le pays sur cette
question des retraites il vous faudra
cette fois plus bien qu'à 49,3 pour vous
en sortir
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés
deux jours de débats qui n'auront pas pu
avoir lieu et d'aider les
constitutionnels toujours plus
contraints voilà à nouveau le constat
que je dresse devant vous voilà le
résultat de cette nouvelle motion de
censure
il y a quelques jours à cette tribune je
vous ai proposé de construire une
nouvelle méthode démocratique
transparente qui respecte les droits
constitutionnels de chacun mais une
méthode qui nous permette aussi de
répondre à notre volonté collective de
pousser plus loin les échanges le débat
et d'aboutir parfois et pardonnez-moi
d'employer ce mot presque indécent pour
certains parmi vous à des compromis
j'ai conscience que ce mot ne sonne pas
juste dans votre partition politique
fondée sur l'affrontement et le blocage
fondé sur la tente presque fébrile d'un
tête à tête avec le rassemblement
national
alors je ne dis pas que le chemin que je
propose est aisé mais une fois encore je
souhaite que nous y travaillons
collectivement faute de quoi nous nous
enfermerons dans une forme de
frustration qui n'aboutira à rien de bon
pour la démocratie elle-même
car en refusant la méthode démocratique
que je vous ai proposé il y a quelques
jours en déposant à nouveau une motion
de censure comme un copier-coller des
précédentes comme à chaque partie à
chaque lecture ce sont bien deux jours
de débat sur le PLF que vous avez retiré
ce sont deux jours précieux compte tenu
du temps qu'il nous reste pour examiner
le texte et disposer d'un budget au 1er
janvier
mesdames et messieurs les députés de la
France insoumis soumisent une fois de
plus vous vous plaignez des conséquences
de ce que vous provoquez par la
multiplication des notions de censure
vous contraignez le temps de la
discussion Vous faites valoir vos droits
constitutionnels constitutionnels cela
n'appelle pas de commentaires de ma part
mais cela a des conséquences que vous
devez assumer chaque motion de censure
se sont au moins deux jours de débat sur
le fond des textes dont vous privez le
Parlement et oui monsieur le Président
cockerel nous n'avons pas la majorité
absolue dans cet assemblée et quand
toutes les oppositions nous disent
vouloir rejeter le PLF quel que soit son
contenu nous prenons nos responsabilités
en engageant la responsabilité du
gouvernement
mais non monsieur le Président Coquerel
cela n'implique pas le dépôt
systématique d'une motion de censure
avec les conséquences que je viens
d'évoquer sur le temps un parti au débat
en trois ans Michel Rocard ses 28 49-3
pour 5motions de censure alors
finalement pourquoi avez-vous si peur du
débat
[Applaudissements]
pas
et je vous rappelle que sur le texte en
première lecture nous avons laissé au
contraire les débats se tenir pendant
plus de 50 heures ainsi madame la
Présidente rabot sur la partie recette
c'est bien 100% du temps prévu qui a été
utilisé j'aurais aimé que ce soit à
nouveau le cas mais par huit fois sur
les textes financiers fidèle à sa
politique de posture permanente le
groupe insoumis a déposé d'émotions de
censure par votre comportement nous
manquons de temps et j'aimerais croire
que les autres groupes de la nuit passe
ne s'y trompent pas
mesdames et messieurs les députés de la
France insoumise vos textes se suivent
et se ressemblent ils respectent ce que
l'on peut maintenant qualifier de
recettes classiques de motion de censure
insoumise contre vérité invictive
attaque tout y est tout y est donc sauf
la volonté de construire de sortir par
le haut
j'en prends acte mais nous devons agir
en responsabilité et la responsabilité
aujourd'hui c'est de s'assurer que la
France dispose d'un budget dans moins
d'un mois
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les députés
j'aimerais de mon côté dire un mot de ce
qui se trouve effectivement dans ce
texte plutôt que de répondre le son à
Séné aux sous-entendu douteux de
Monsieur le Député Lucas je n'ai pas de
son de République à recevoir de vous
monsieur le député je n'ai pas de leçon
de démocratie à recevoir de vous quand
vous sacrifiez le temps du débat prévu
sur le PLF pour tenter pour la 8e fois
de nous censurer
donc la séance est reprise voici le
résultat du scrutin majorité requise
pour l'adoption de la motion de censure
sur la majorité absolue des membres
composant l'assemblée 288 pour
l'adoption 78 la majorité requise
n'étant pas atteinte la motion de
censure n'est pas adoptée en conséquence
la première partie du projet de loi de
finance pour 2023 est considéré comme
adopté en nouvelle lecture